[Music]
feels like
those who have promised to
help me through this stuff not i don't
mean my wife or my family
it feels like
everything is reinforced in the idea
that in this i'm totally alone why
struggle through it anymore and just
kind of end it you know
[Music]
what's up this is john with dr john
delony show
talking about your mental health your
relationships and your life and the good
stuff and the hard stuff whatever's
going on
if you want to be on the greatest mental
health show ever says my mom actually
she like dr phil better i think she's
gonna be on the second or third greatest
mental health show ever give me a call
at
1-844-693-3291 it's 1-844-693-3291
ask today's a special show
um we've got somebody calling in
um later on in the show
that um i'm looking forward to um kind
of called his bluff and he called mom
back or i challenged him he called my
bluff and i'm excited to talk to him
so uh hang with us this entire show it's
it's gonna be a powerful one let's go
straight to the phones let's go to
michael in buffalo what's up michael
right at that time
[Music]
what's up man
so i uh
the reason i wanted to talk to you is my
question is i've uh haven't been a good
husband or father
and my wife now who i've been with for
five years is that with end and
i just i want to be that man that she
deserves and i just i fail miserably
in every step that i tried to do
anything
well first thanks for being brave um
usually these kind of calls end up with
me coming at you a little bit is that
cool
yes sir all right
i'm straight up with that cool uh well
thanks for thanks for being open man i
know that's not an easy thing to say to
look in the mirror and put both hands on
the counter and look in the mirror and
say i'm i'm i'm not the man and the
husband and the
dad i want to be so thanks for starting
there um what does that mean that you're
not
good uh well
she's my uh she's my second wife my
first marriage uh
ended
pretty bad just because i wasn't
faithful uh to her
and uh and multiple times so it's
basically a serial cheater and liar and
then i went on just to
basically live it how i wanted to and
then i met my wife now and
and
some of those same traits or aspects are
coming back out you know she uh
sometimes i'm not truthful or
you know i lie and it's not just that i
lie but then when i lie i guess i go
slate
and try to make her believe my lie and
and
you know i've been unloyal to her in
ways of you know
talking about
things with that relationship involving
her but putting the blame more on her
than myself
and uh you know even to the point where
a lot of things she says you know it
just appears that i'm selfish and
narcissistic and you know i lack you
know empathy and haven't been faithful
to her you know
you know infidelity not it's not that
i've cheated on her i haven't cheated on
her i think you have yes i think you
have
yeah i mean she i mean she said you know
i've not physically cheated on her but
at the beginning like i did talk to
other women but then that stopped but
then like i've you know financially i
have you know shown infidelity
emotionally
um so and she's she's she's a great
woman she straight up tells me how it is
and she reminds me of a female version
of you hey look hold on let's let's
start
this only works
if you you're honest with me
yes sir have you cheated on your wife
i have not
absolutely not and i've told her that
you know of course she doesn't believe
me because i've that's my door yeah i
have never that's one area that and i've
told her like like i heard my lesson in
that she makes me happy she fulfills me
and i i know you know she's not she's
not the issue and your first wife wasn't
the issue
exactly i've been the issue for some
reason you believe that you're not good
enough why
yeah well it's
i mean i have things from my past that
uh what i've brought
well
for years in my first marriage i uh and
never and never brought it up until
going to counseling with my first wife
and uh even my parents never knew i was
i was molested as a child okay i i held
that in my neighbor boy who babysat me
okay and i held that in for all those
years and uh
you know as far as like the the
asus score like i've done that like i i
don't score high on that so it's you
know my parents are together i
you know have a good family um i'm the
only one in the family divorce my
siblings are married and happy
i know but listen listen listen when you
when you have something like that
then your body learns that there is no
safety in
trusting relationships
and so when you have a trusting
relationship
everything in your body says run says
discomfort
it sounds every alarm you got
it does and one of the ways to shut the
alarms off is alcohol and one of the
ways to shut the alarms off is to go
achieve just start running right work 90
hours a week and one of the ways to shut
the alarms off is to go sleep with
someone else or if you're not
technically sleeping with somebody else
another way to shut the alarms off is to
start texting somebody and texting
somebody and texting somebody because
you get that little bitty
it feels good right it feels like you're
live for a second right yes yes sir it
did
so think of it this way and again i'm
being super simplistic here but let's
just say one story equals one action
okay
your body knows that intimate
relationships are going to get you hurt
and so when you enter into one it covers
you up with those big heavy weighted
blankets
right and you can't breathe and you get
scared and you don't like who you become
right and then you go chase excitement
right
and ultimately
my guess is you've beat yourself up
pretty bad over the last few years and
to be honest with you rightfully so
because you're treating these women who
loved you like garbage right
you're running through this cycle that
you believe that you're not good enough
and the truth isn't good enough
and so you confirm it by your actions
right that you're not a good dad you're
not a good husband and then you just do
the things that backfill that story and
make it right
and so
you
i think jenna told me you read you read
the book you read my book
did that rattle your cage at all did you
roll your eyes at it
no i didn't i didn't read it i actually
listened to it online through one of the
library services um
it was good it was really good and i
shared it with my wife and my wife loves
you she you know she listens we both
listen to you uh all the time so
um she actually told her about certain
parts and you know how i need to go i
actually want to get the book so i can
actually keep notes on it and and try to
take the steps in there that you've you
uh emphasize what have you tried what
have you tried
uh
i
as far as the booklets
throw the book out you use it for
two-ply on a camping trip i don't care
about the book
what have you tried
to stop lying to your family to stop
cheating on your family
yeah and and that's and i you know with
my wife i've tried you know being open
and not lying to her about things and
then you know of course at times when i
am truthful about things
getting the reactions
i know you know either i get the
reaction or i'm projecting what the
reaction is going to be and then it
basically triggers me into like well i
don't want that reaction so i'm going to
say this so i get a different reaction
and and then that lie
ultimately triggers a worse reaction
right
so so here here's your way forward ma'am
here's your way forward
i wish it was more complex than what i'm
about to say
at some point
like an alcoholic has to look in the
mirror and say i i
i want to
but i can never drink again
yes
um
or like me
i want to
but i have a problem with food i do
and so i have to create an environment
where
i can only make good choices
just it
you have to decide
point blank i will never lie again
right you have to decide point blank i
will never cheat again and then you have
to create a world that makes that very
very difficult and you have to practice
it that's it
i wish it was more complex than that
it's just simply not
and i tell you this as someone who lied
a lot i exaggerated about everything and
i watched a professional ex just implode
their life
and it was this weird moment that was
i will never be dishonest again for as
long as i live
right
and it has been really uncomfortable
and when i say practice here's what that
means you will lie again it becomes
second nature right and you're probably
pretty good at it and it just comes out
you stop either right then or you circle
back and you say
i didn't tell you the truth and you have
to tell your wife i need some grace when
i circle back here was the rule i gave
my students like when i called them in
and said hey
they found a bunch of drugs in your
residence hall room
i would always tell them before i talk
to you i need you to know you got 24
hours and i'm gonna i'm going to take it
as though you told me the truth now
because i know what happens when someone
just blasts you with an accusation it's
so easy it's second nature just to go no
no no if you come back within 24 hours
and change your story i'm gonna i'm
gonna take it as though you told me that
the first time after 24 hours i'm going
to try to remove you from this campus
because you're a dishonest person and i
don't want our degree hanging on your
wall
right right so yeah come up with some
sort of contract with your wife and say
i'm going to practice with all that i am
just be a person of integrity
and that means there's going to be
moments that i fire off with something
that's not true and i need to catch
myself in that moment
or i need that moment to haunt me so bad
that i loop back and change it and i
need you to hear me and exhale and say
okay he's working hard
right practice not being a cheater means
you delete every single woman in your
phone that's not your wife now and you
delete social media now
yes i don't even have social media so
if you have a problem with pornography
and checking out um uh
all the various sites for getting into
people's living rooms and in their bed
then get rid of your computer
you're an addict
yes and your addiction is deception
right and then underneath all that man
at some point you've got to decide that
you're not a piece of crap
yeah that's
that's the
biggest challenge it is it is you gotta
love yourself you gotta you gotta you
know
you gotta be truthful to yourself and
but no you're not truthful to yourself
yeah you lie to yourself you tell
yourself that you suck and you tell
yourself that you're an idiot and you
tell yourself that you're worth the
abuse and you should have done something
different and now you're the divorced
one in the house
and you are you've got all these stories
that you continue to tell yourself over
and over and over and over again
yes and you got to choose to change that
story
i also believe like i told you the
reason i told you actions first is i
think we can't just sit especially as a
one as deeply and traumatic and
entrenched as what you experienced with
sexual abuse from an older kid in your
neighborhood
i don't think you can think your way out
of that i think you act your way out of
that and you act your way out by
practicing
practice the new behaviors
right
okay
and a hundred percent chance you will
stumble and fail and fall right on your
face
and that's when you become the husband
and
dad that your wife and kids need because
you pick yourself back up
and you say i'm sorry and then you go
again
yeah it's nice my answers have become
unheard
of they should be they mean nothing
right right and so it's be about
reclaiming that word in your home you're
if you listen remember listen in the
book the
and i got this from
uh james clear
create an identity and backfill your
life so that that identity becomes
natural meaning don't try to i want to
bench press 235 pounds that's a goal and
you'll stumble on that goal
right
or you'll get the goal and then so what
you can benchmaster 235 pounds nobody
cares you're a grown man
be a person who takes care of their body
be a person who's a steward of everybody
so you're gonna be a person who's a
great father and backfilling that
identity i always tell the truth always
i don't cheat on my kid's mother
right when i'm having bad days or when
my body takes off on me i had a really
hard day yesterday michael you know what
i did i left i cancelled all my meetings
i left because i knew that i would be i
would not be able to
be present in conversations and i knew
conversations with me
i would be very sharp tongue i just know
that
it's rare that it happens but i knew it
and so i took myself out of situation
okay that we're looking for this type of
self-awareness here and you don't have
it yet
right okay
yes so i would ask you are your kids
worth it you know the answer is yes is
your wife worth it you know the answer
is yes
the ultimate question is are you
yes
do you believe that are you lying to me
too i i believe it i believe it
okay will you do the work then
i will definitely do the work and that's
you know i've been telling her i'm
working on it but she's like i don't see
it yet she doesn't she doesn't because i
don't think you're working on it i think
you're wanting to work on it i think
you're tr it's kind of like
every couple of days you skip the donuts
in the work room and you tell people
you're trying to eat better
that's not a plan
right very good point right
yes sir that's exactly dead end
yep
you've gotta set out an identity here's
who i'm gonna be then you've gotta
backfill those actions and quite
honestly at this point i'd bring her
along with you right
and say what does real estate spend more
of her time
but see that's just that's what that
goes back to that same you just dumped
it back in the bucket you're a waste of
somebody's time you're not
yeah you're treating your wife like crap
but you yourself are not a waste of time
right you're not a lost cause and the
more you think about oh well i'll just
that's actually a move dude that's a
deceptive move
right yeah yeah and i'm not saying i'm a
waste of time i'm saying i don't want to
waste her time then don't
then don't then don't you get to choose
that
right right
yes sir
exactly right don't waste your time
sit down and say what does rebuilding
trust look like and if you would like
um i'll clip this call and we'll send it
to you it doesn't come out for a while
but we'll clip it to you and send it to
you and you and your wife can listen to
it tonight or tomorrow that's it she
would absolutely love it okay
so here's what i need y'all both need to
sit at a table
and she's got to put some hard
boundaries on you because this is just
going to go and it's going to go and
it's going to go and your second
marriage is going to end up just like
your first one
right don't do that to her don't do that
to you don't do that to those kids
i will never lie again
and when i do i will admit it i will own
it and i will practice circling back out
of it and i'm going to let her speak
into how do i get out
i will never
be disloyal and dishonorable to my wife
again
period
i will see her on every text on every
email i send to another woman i will
come home she will see the bank accounts
we will share bank accounts if you don't
already that happens today i'm gonna do
these things that will
show
this is who i am
and this is who i am becoming this is
who i'm on the road to be and give her
some voice into what trust looks like
and then she's gonna have a role to play
too because she's gonna have to be
graceful because you're trying something
that you have not been successful with
for a long long time
and if ultimately you got to go get some
counseling to deal with that childhood
trauma which is a big one i don't care
what your ace score is that's a huge
thing
to get some healing with that do it
but i'm gonna tell you i'm i'm
bifurcated i'm separating that from your
actions you can stop cheating
and you can stop lying
and you can't stop
uh being dishonest with your money and
with your wife all that stuff
and you have to deal with your childhood
stuff it's all it's it's it can be
braided together i'm pulling it apart
choose to be different my brother
call me back after that meeting let me
know how that meeting goes we'll be
right back
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too
i love living in a new home but i gotta
be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and they'll
try to upsell you a bunch of nonsense
that's going to hurt you down the road
and most importantly when you're making
this big life change you can actually
breathe because you've got an expert in
a team who have your back listen if
you're about to buy a home and make a
big change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple h
loan 200. trust me that's triple eight
loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 in the mls consumeraccess.org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane sweet
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right we're back let's go to beth in
tucson arizona what's up beth
hi how's it going we are rocking on how
are you
good you know just trying to stay cool
oh yeah you're in arizona dude it's a
million degrees
you're trying to stay not dead
yes exactly so hot
ah so hot so what's up
okay so my question today is um how can
i best be a friend to my best friend who
has been battling cancer for three years
and continues to just get bad news after
bad news
what's bad news
um
yeah i don't i'm trying not to go too
deep into
telling her story for her but
basically it's at the point now where
um it's alternate treatments and okay so
it's terminal yeah okay um well and
that's the thing that's hard about being
a friend too is it
you know i'm getting the information
from her as she's as she's willing to
share or and i know she's not wanting to
give up hope also and so
um but it's it's i know that it's we're
at a hard place for sure
cool so yeah so how can i help i'm so
sorry i mean i oh no so sorry yeah i
think it's just you know i've we've been
going through this um i've been you know
with her for the last few years through
covet and through everything it's been
such a weird time to battle something
like this and i think i'm just finding
myself
not sure how to be there for her or how
to
i just want to be her friend i just want
to hang out and i just want to go for a
run with her but obviously that's not
where we are and so i just find myself
feeling a little helpless with how i can
just be there for her as a friend in
this moment and kind of balance that
with kind of you know the grief that i'm
dealing with um
and i think too over the last couple
months have started to realize that i'm
grieving the friendship we had because
you know it's we
we've trained for triathlons together
we've done all this stuff together we've
raised our kids together
and it's just um
yeah i'm just finding myself in a really
heavy place and i'm not sure
i'm trying to take care of myself and
make sure you know i just went on a
family vacation and trying to i keep
telling my husband i'm trying to hold
the joy and the grief at the same time
and it's really difficult
but i'm just at this point trying to
figure out how i can best be there for
her as she's navigating this
one she's lucky to have you
and thanks for articulating that that
way you you laid it out perfectly that
that balance is so hard
how old are you
um we're both 35.
oh my gosh
well it's um colorectal cancer it's
either colon cancer yeah yeah breast
cancer yeah
yeah
so
yeah so what a mess
um
okay uh we'll loop through a couple of
things here all right
okay um
i'll start with you and then we'll work
out is that cool
yes um
first this is gonna be hard to hear
joy is
often on the other side of grief
and you can make yourself insane trying
to force one and hold the other
okay
and so
this is a season of grief
for a hundred different reasons and it's
not selfish for you to grieve the loss
of your friendship
and it's not selfish to grieve the loss
of the plans you guys had to do a
triathlon when you're 40. and to be
those two wrinkly old 50 year old ladies
running in the neighborhood
like you had that picture in your head
and grieving that is the right thing to
do because it's not going to happen
because it's not going to happen
yeah that's i think that's the hard part
is that um
you know what she's dealing with is so
much heavier than this yeah
listen
listen do not ever ever ever
compare grief
okay your grief is yours
okay
okay that's a fool's errand and
everybody ends up worse off when we
compare grief
her looking at you going oh you think
you've got it bad i've got this if she
thinks that that doesn't help her cancer
no she's not that way of course she's
not right but i heard it a lot during
kovid like oh well my husband lost his
job but at least not like dennis my
friend's husband who's on a ventilator
it's like well at least my husband
didn't die everybody's life was hard
right
and so own where you are right now
the one recurring challenge i hear from
people who are
get cancer
is that they say the hardest part of
getting cancer is often
making sure everyone else in their life
is okay
yeah and i'm very aware of that okay i'm
trying not to be that person to her um
and i'm trying to
the hardest part is just not
i obviously i want to know how she's
doing and how but trying to find some
normalcy as in our friendship okay
listen there's nothing
i know it's not i'm just trying to i'm
trying to i it's like i just want to
give her a break
from this heaviness and i know i can't
but
yeah it's hard so as a person who's a
triathlete as a person who's going on
vacations and
writing down in your planner that we
will have joy right which is probably
who you are
um yes there's nothing more terrifying
and nothing more um
um
there's no more feeling mortal
than watching someone who's very similar
to you
die
yes
and you can't control it
no and the control part is what makes
you nuts
yeah the letting go part and the being
really really sad and the grieving this
that's where there will like be light on
the other end of it but you got to go
through the black hole first i wish
there was another one yeah
and i just think it's hard because i
mean i was at the we were at the park
with our kids the other day and it's
like it's
it's surreal right she's still here
she's still here she's still my friend
you would never look at her and even
know that she's sick um yeah it's very
hard yeah it is
all right so
i want you to loosen the control
and this is gonna sound bonkers i want
you to lean into this discomfort not
away from it
okay lean into it and don't try to
control it okay
what that looks like is keep a record a
journal of how you're feeling
if you haven't started something keep it
and it'll be a great gift for her kids
one day
okay
what you're gonna miss about her
what you'll miss about you after she's
gone
that you're scared and alone and
terrified
and there's days you just want to go hug
her and make this all better and you
can't write all that down because here's
what you're gonna do for her kids
you're gonna give them some words and
language to the hurt they feel after
mommy's gone
okay
okay
i also want you to this is going to
sound bonkers but have you sat down and
asked her what do you need
um no
ta-da
so okay um
you there's nothing worse
than dating a guy and men are the worst
about this about dating a guy and
he's like
i know what i'm getting her for
valentine's day a great makeout session
and yeah you know what i mean like and
he's got all these ideas for how he's
gonna truly honor her and i always like
when my buddies
have you have you asked your wife what
she wants because what she really might
want the greatest most romantic gift you
could give her is like you to go away
that could be awesome or to do the
dishes right so i tell you this when
somebody's hurting we often rush to fix
that person's hurt because we feel
uncomfortable and we're actually trying
to heal our own discomfort
right
i want you
to go ask your friend
i love you we've done hard things
together and we're entering into mile
28.
and this is an uncharted run for both of
us
what do you need right now yeah if you
need me to stay away because every time
you see me you grieve what you're not
gonna have i'll stay away
if you need me to show up and just bring
tacos and ride this sucker down i'm
gonna let my nutrition go and we're
gonna eat beer drink beer and eat nachos
until this thing rides up
yeah
ask her what she needs
yeah and i think there's been seasons of
that i just think um
yeah i've just been in this
the last
few months of extra heaviness um
yeah don't try to fight the extra
heaviness because it's gonna come anyway
and quite honestly it's gonna take you
with it
um can we do this um kelly
um is a cancer survivor and
um
i would love to is it cool if i get her
inside on this yeah oh yes kelly would
you willing to say something of course
okay so
you may tell me john you're an idiot
that was terrible wisdom there you give
her um walk it through you get the
cancer diagnosis and then there's the
scary season yours obviously wasn't it
wasn't terminal but quite the same thing
um walk us through your experience yeah
hey beth so one thing that john said
about asking her
i i actually raised my hands because it
was such a huge moment yes
my boss here
um
one of the greatest gifts he gave me was
he asked me how do you want us to treat
you
um okay and i would and my answer was
like you did yesterday
and before all this because i didn't
want to be
babied and
everyone felt sorry for me and so by him
asking that
and i knew if i had said
well i'm i'm a little emotional so i
need you to be nicer to me they would
have done it he would have done it
but right the fact that he
let me be an adult
and didn't assume how i wanted to be
treated he allowed me to make that
decision
and then the biggest biggest thing is
when you're the person that has cancer
or any issue other people's
feelings are exhausting
yes absolutely they really are they are
exhausting
and that was harder for me to deal with
in anything was everybody else's need to
tell me how i was going to be fine and
i'm so sorry and i'll pray for you i
know everybody meant well by the time i
went home i was like crawling in bed
just because i was so tired
so yes i can feel that yeah finding
another way for that outlet your husband
another friend
um
yeah with her very very careful with
that and yeah i think i mean one thing
that's been you know when we're with our
kids it's easy to just be moms and to be
present with each other and to laugh at
our kids and have those late moments so
i've tried we've leaned into that but
yeah i definitely um yeah i think
it's um you know i've given the hey let
me know how i can help or what i can do
but not as direct of hey what how can i
be different i mean i'm asking you
beth you just said something asked her
you said something really important
don't hang on to yeah when y'all are
just being moms and y'all just playing
with your kids you know just hanging out
that's one of the greatest gifts you can
give her yes but when you go home
that feeling you feel that's your grief
not hers yes
right and it's not her job to make that
grief go away put her your grief on her
no definitely not yet right
she's getting
she's never going to forget she has
cancer
and if you don't talk about it or
you know all of a sudden you just
pretend like the old days trust me she's
not gonna forget she's getting it from
her probably her husband her doctors and
a million other people that mean well
and everybody at her church
she needs somebody to treat her like a
friend yeah just to i mean not
everything's not going to be normal but
someone that's going to laugh and you
know make fun of her if that's what you
i mean my friends and i are completely
totally sarcastic so you know when i had
my mastectomy there was jokes
lots lots of jokes
because that's what i needed i didn't
need somebody to pet me and go oh i'm so
very sorry i had plenty of that
i needed my friends to be my friends
still because i needed a sense of
normalcy
okay yeah so as much of that as you can
do and hey what can i do for you they're
never gonna no one's ever gonna say
well actually i really need someone to
go the store just step in and say i'm
going to the store what do you want me
to get
yeah or i'm on my way over what do you
want from starbucks
yeah because people hate to ask
especially if they're like me they don't
want to ask for help
exactly so just stepping in and doing it
getting over there and just being her
friend
okay yeah and there's going to be some
weird moments thank you so much kelly
that's awesome um
my oldest greatest friends on the planet
is a paraplegic he's in a wheelchair
and
i've been stopped
we've been stopped in like in
like restaurant parking lots
um because we're hassling each other so
much like somebody came and got into
into me and his little brother's face it
was like how dare you talk to him that
way and we were like whoa whoa whoa whoa
he's our friend he's our friend and
you it may be that she comes up to the
park with her friend and you're like
nice haircut and she's like i know and
somebody's gonna look at you mean
whatever they don't get a vote this is
your friendship yeah right yeah or maybe
she looks at you goes i need you to
treat me like a princess great done no
and i mean i think i
it's it's really good to hear because i
mean we've always
throughout her treatments and through
and there's another friend involved who
doesn't live in town with us but um
you know we send each other funny memes
and all that stuff and i've kind of
stopped doing that because i'm like i
don't i know but i think maybe it's okay
we need to
keep the fun going and maybe be willing
especially
listen so yeah ask her
yeah because there will um my friend her
name was kelly and when she died of
cancer
she had brain cancer very very very
young
and
when it first when she her first couple
years of diagnosis
everybody knew it was terminal from day
one they shouldn't know how long and
when she first got it she talked to
everybody she would go talk to the kids
in the cancer ward she would tell
hilarious jokes and we were relentless
back
she's one of the most extraordinary
women i've ever met
but as they got further along and the
timeline was getting shorter and shorter
it was very clear
it's not funny and we're not going to
make jokes and what we want now is more
closeness and more hand-holding and more
the hugs to be a little bit tighter and
it just shifted and everybody kept
checking in with what do you need what
do you need what do you need
and so um
let her steer that ship and even if you
have to say from this point forward i'm
going to let you steer this like you
tell me what you need and i'm going to
keep asking you once a week i'm going to
ask you
let me know how we can best love you
and you find support and love and care
for your grief maybe you and your other
friend
you all go get together you all go out
you all write each other letters
whatever that looks like
um
serve her kids whatever that looks like
but find outlets for that grief there
too
and i'll reiterate what i said earlier
she's really lucky to have you as her
friend
man
thank you for loving hurting people beth
you're awesome we'll be right back
hey what's up delona here i've got a
word from our sponsor better help i'm
always getting calls about burnout what
it is what to do about it and just how
to live feeling this way
burnout is when your body has enough and
it says i'm out i'm done it's that deep
feeling of exhaustion after a long
period of being overworked and
overstressed and just fried and most of
us associate burnout with work but
burnout can happen at any area of our
lives and it can cause a lack of
motivation irritability fatigue or
randomly crying at some random song on
the radio or when somebody looks at you
the wrong way and that's why i love my
friends at better help better help
online therapy exists to give you the
chance to invest in your healing
betterhelp is customized online therapy
that offers video phone and even live
chat sessions with you and your
therapist you never have to even see
anyone on camera if you don't want to
it's more affordable than in-person
therapy plus you can be matched with the
therapist in under 48 hours and today
our listeners get ten percent off their
first month at
betterhelp.com that's betterhelphelp.com
all right we are back let's go to ashley
in the nyc what's up ashley
hey doctor john great to talk to you you
too what's up
um so
i'm just gonna jump right into it jump
right into it swan dive into
so i am extremely protective of my
mother um she is on the autism spectrum
and
[Music]
her way of processing the world makes
her very vulnerable okay
um so she has survived four abusive
husbands
um actually i should say we've survived
because it really impacted my brother
and i too
um
but uh her last her fourth marriage her
last marriage ended pretty dramatically
back in december 2020
um we'd all kind of felt like we'd
reached the finish line of this
toxic relationship you know these toxic
relationship choices but
now she has announced that she's in love
again um after only a couple dates
and of course this guy shows
the same red flags as all the other
husbands
so i don't know
we've been through this so many times
and i don't know if any of us can go
through this cycle for a fifth time
so i guess my question is
how do i protect my mom from choosing
another
toxic husband
oh she's so lucky to have you as her
daughter um
how
i i'm gonna be 100 honest is that cool
yes
you can't
there is literally
nothing you can do
and what i would suggest you do how old
are you
uh mid-40s okay
um i would suggest you look back
over the last 20 years
at all of the ways you've tried to
protect her and the talks and the
conversations and the texts and the mean
faces at the husbands and all those
things
and none of that has worked
and there's something defeatist and sad
and honest
about saying
i can't fix this
short of some clinical diagnostic that
gave you guardianship of your mother
because she was uncapable of taking care
of herself and i don't think if she's
able to get married on
i don't think you'd you would qualify
for that
right yeah not yet
so ultimately here's a hard thing
i've had to do it every family member
every person with a family i know who's
interested in boundaries has had to do
this
is you have to there comes a moment when
that family member also becomes a person
it's become the person that you love and
is your family
but they're also a person who is hurting
you
right and at some point you have to
make sure that you're well
especially in a feudal situation like
this and so what i would do is tell your
mom
very specifically
i'm not i'm choosing to not go through
number five
you're an adult
you're allowed to make decisions on your
own
but every time you are hurt it hurts me
and i can't am choosing to not be hurt a
fifth time
and so if she chooses to
move away from you and go towards this
relationship that's going to hurt
but there's nothing you can do about it
because you've tried four other times
right
right but i feel like i'm leaving her
alone in another abusive situation like
i've always been her support system like
kind of
you've been the adult
and i feel like i'd be leaving her
completely in the wilderness all by
herself if i distance myself
what's the other option
i guess going through it again
does that make sense is that does that
help her
how have you how have you helped her the
other four times
um
i can be very honest
very honest
um
husband number two and three i actually
i would say helped run them off in a way
um
counseled her through it you know helped
her
recognize the toxicity you know talked
about her she hasn't recognized anything
how valuable she is she hasn't heard
that message recognize it for a while
yeah she'll see it and then she'll break
it off
my guess is she sees that you are more
engaged with her
right not
that she's got some toxic thought
patterns and relationship patterns that
she needs to do something different with
and i don't know if that's because of
her cognitive capacity i don't know if
that's because of childhood traumas or
both who knows why
but the reality is she hasn't learned
those messages and so this is going to
be really ugly what i'm about to say
the help that you have given her has
been
you've loved her
and you have loved her unconditionally
and you have continued to walk alongside
her the lessons you've given her have
not worked
and that's what i'm saying
you're continuing to pour water into a
bucket with hole with a hole in it
and so here's what boundaries look like
the same as you probably do with your
kids which is
you will always have a place to stay
he will not be welcome
you will always um i'll always take care
of you but from this point forward
you're gonna come this way
i unless you decide uh are you married
no okay unless you decide your brother
decide well here we go again we're just
gonna be in this and if so make peace
with that make don't fight that yeah
make peace with it yeah i am my mother's
ninja warrior and that's just what i do
i i fight
i
help run off bad guys
right and then she attracts the next one
and then i run that guy yeah
if that if you choose it feels nice in
the moment there's a lot of resentment i
think attacked
that that i've never told her because i
don't want to hurt her feelings but
is she unable to
why are you why are you protect her so
much
well
she sees the world
differently so she the way that she
processes the world she takes everything
very
literally she doesn't understand sarcasm
manipulation deceit you know these kind
of things and so
she is very easy to be lied to because
she'll believe anything that somebody
tells her
and i think for whatever reason she
attracts men
who
will lie to her
and when she's in love
logic goes out the window
she doesn't see anything
but i think that if it were anybody else
who
who could kind of wake up and realize
the manipulation
and the lies
i would back off probably more but i
feel like unless i am there to
i would say almost interpret for her
what's happening in front of her and to
lay the foundation this is manipulation
what he said to you isn't true you're
worth more than that you realize that
you know whatever
if i'm not there to interpret the
situation for her
i feel like she would actually be in a
worse
position
than she's already found herself in so i
do see myself as a protector
which i would
probably just keep doing if it didn't
impact
me in the process
so you know i don't know you want both
sides of the fence
you can't i do well i just don't want to
resent her for it
so i want to still help her you've got
to choose to not be to not be resentful
which means you got to carry yourself
right and so if you're choosing to look
at this as though you're you're caring
for
an adult with special needs
and that she is a danger to herself
or she just has no ability to protect
herself from danger
that's a totally different pathway
that's i'm gonna seek to get control of
her finances
and i'm gonna seek to get control uh i'm
gonna pay her rent using her money i'm
gonna pay her rent right
which i actually do i am in control of
her finances since the fourth marriage
okay great so she hand willingly handed
that over to me so that's a good
excellent
i know that this community doesn't like
this phrasing is it's it's just easier
in the short term the highly functioning
autistic folks i've worked with
have been the best people to get very
very clear boundaries
if you do this i will no longer be
accessible to you
you are choosing him or you are choosing
me
and that is a choice that you get to
make
and so i don't know what that boundary
looks like all i can do is look at the
last
four rounds and realize that that hasn't
worked
and so i
the other side of it is if you choose to
love your mom by walking alongside her
and protecting her
um
i would come up with some even firmer
boundaries
like
uh i mean
i don't really know how to do that um
i do i don't know how to do it in this
situation without sitting down with both
you and your brother and your mom
um
what i mean by that is continue to
you've got money you've got hopefully
got retirement accounts hopefully you've
got bank accounts hopefully you've got
insurance stuff hopefully you're paying
the bills and so some new person doesn't
have access my fear is that some new
person is going to come give some very
compelling reasons and she's going to
revoke that access for you
um and that then you'll end up in a mess
or you
ask for guardianship and you ask her to
sign over guardianship for you and that
may be a path forward when it comes to
really really strong boundaries or you
put her in some sort of assisted living
facility or something
ultimately
you've got to decide how you're going to
do this and when you make that decision
don't resent don't get mad at the other
side of it because both sides are a
choice either you're going to step out
and say these are my boundaries and
there's a potential mom's going to go
off the rails
and become victim to somebody who's a
predator or you're going to be all in
protecting mom
and you just know you're going to lose a
lot of weekends over it because that's a
choice that you made but once you make
that choice
be at peace with it be at peace with it
be at peace with it and i know that's
hard you have to practice being you have
to and that's where you have to sleep
take care of your body all those things
you have to eat right you have to have
your friends you have to do all that
stuff too that you know
but make your choice and exhale through
it and i'm sorry that you're in this i
know this sounds so hard it just sounds
hard hard hard
like i said in the beginning your mom's
super lucky to have you
make a choice and make peace with it
i'm sorry we'll be right back
it seems so easy but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships i'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up or you can share
hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to johndaloni.com to
take the next step towards wellness
that's own your past change your future
at johndaloni.com
all right we are back and as promised um
we've got a special fourth call today
um
just a few shows ago
talk to somebody who lives um
uh somewhat close to me here in
nashville
whose uh husband was struggling with
suicidal ideation and he'd driven
himself to a bridge as a veteran um done
a lot of tours a really extraordinary
man
and i asked her why we were talking um
can i talk to him right now is he at
home and she said he wasn't home and i
said i'd love to talk to him
and he's a brave man and he called
and so uh we've got justin here from
tennessee from middle tennessee here hey
justin what's up man
how you doing john i'm good my brother
how are you
i'm doing all right doing all right
um man
i i get to deal with brave people all
day long and this tops the list my man
so thank you so much for having the
courage to call
oh well thank you for taking my call
yeah man so uh
you talked to your wife tell me how that
conversation went
um well it's been an ongoing
conversation since um since she talked
to you sort of things have been coming
up um but
overall yeah good good conversation um
we've been learning a lot over the last
few days
so tell me what's been going on the last
three months four months five months and
the years before that
um
gosh
so it's it's it i feel kind of like
synthesis um
except that there's
um
like i'm not getting to the top of the
hill right um i feel like i'm i'm
climbing uphill um it's muddy i'm up to
my nose
and um i'm not not ever getting anywhere
and it feels like all of the alarm bells
in in my head are are always going off
at the little things yeah right
um
i tried getting uh and what's more it
feels like i'm i'm doing all of that
alone
uh it feels like
those who have promised to
help me through this stuff not i don't
mean my wife or my family
um but but counselors and and and the
freaking va
the the va okay you name them nonsense
i'll name them because it's an atrocity
sometimes the way they treat you guys
it's unbelievable man
and i'm a freaking taxpayer i pay their
bills it's unbelievable man it's
unbelievable
yeah but it's just it's it felt like an
abandonment um you know one one time
after another i mean even just last week
two weeks ago um two days before an
appointment i after being on the suicide
hotline and all that stuff they canceled
two days beforehand
were gonna get me another appointment
for late august you know
and so just kind of been dragged along
and so everything just kind of
it feels like
everything is
reinforcing the idea that
uh in this i'm totally alone
that i'm never gonna get anywhere
nothing's gonna change
uh utterly just just hopeless there's
there's nothing there so um just
why why struggle through it anymore and
just kind of end it you know absolutely
absolutely well thanks for man you
articulated that well um wha what are
you pushing uphill
great mythological reference by the way
my mom's a mythologist that was awesome
um
what are you pushing uphill
man uh i think it may just be my own
weight i don't know
you're pushing something what is it
yeah i don't know i mean if if i could
if if i could see something if i could
name something i think even just that
alone might help but i mean it feels
like i mean we've we've gone through
some
frustrating boundary issues with you
know i mean everybody's calling in for
about that kind of thing
you know
my sister's going through a nasty
divorce we've got all this all this
stuff it feels like you know
things just just keep piling up but but
none of it's singular enough that i'm
able to to identify it yeah
so
um
how many combat tours did you do
two two you see some stuff
i did
um
any of that stay on a loop with you or
no
not really um
i i mean i almost wish it was because
because that's easy to identify and go
after
yeah all right so i'm i'm gonna
oversimplify this okay but i hope this
works i hope this rings true to you okay
um and i'll tell you the first time i
ever had this conversation
um
was with a
um an israeli combat veteran who was one
of my students
um who had
been way
into the trenches with hezbollah the
whole thing
and was
uncoming unhinged when a teacher would
call on him in the classroom
and he didn't understand it
and so let me paint a broad picture okay
so you've
if you haven't heard me i'll just start
from scratch here
your body is basically a giant
prediction machine and a giant alarm
system that's it
okay
and that's oversimplified but that's
basically what it is
and when things happen to us in our
childhood things happen to us in combat
things happen to us in a car wreck
things happen just in divorce whatever
it puts a gps pin in that thing
and it has one job and that's to get us
to tomorrow and then get us to the next
day and get us to the next day that's
why we'll smoke today
we know it's gonna kill us later but it
gets us to tomorrow because i'm stressed
now right right
and sometimes
often if you will if you look around at
the veteran community especially
um
that alarm system has so many pins and
so many things and it only has one
volume
and it loses the ability to be sensitive
and so the best way i could describe
that is
um you've been in a house and the the
smoke alarms going off in the kitchen
because somebody's burning something
and it's so loud and obnoxious and
there's little kids in there and
everybody's screaming it's like so loud
that's the same alarm that goes off when
the house is on fire and someone's
dumped gasoline in it
and
that fire will go off i mean that alarm
will go off sometimes if somebody's
running the shower too hot and it's
steam out there now now that right so
the alarm just becomes so sensitive
that it rings off the hook for any
number of things and you you nailed it
perfectly
it just feels like there's a lot all the
time if you think about that a lot
feeling
it's very similar to being in a house or
being in a building and they're working
on the fire alarms and they're just
going off you can't write you can't tax
you can't do anything you can't have a
conversation you can't do anything you
especially can't eat well
and go to the gym and have any sort of
meaningful
sex life i mean you can't do these
things that bring you you can't connect
with your kids because going
right
here's what i'm telling you that
you're not broken
and you are not malfunctioning
your alarm system is
and i need you to step away
from identifying with a component
got what i'm saying
okay you're not broken
we do need to work on that alarm system
yeah okay
and the entry point into you're not
broken
is curiosity not frustration
here's what i mean by that
the next time
you think
what am i doing here
i know how this ends
bye honey
that's the moment where you pause
and all i'm asking for brother is a
pause
and you ask yourself the question
what is my body trying to protect me
from right now
and if you can ask that question that's
the pathway to peace and that's the
pathway to getting this alarm system
back
see what i'm saying
yes what's this trying to protect me
from
oh
i'm having a hard conversation here
we're planning for the future and i
don't see a future for myself
there's so much noise in the system like
what is this protecting me from
is it the showers running or is the
house actually on fire
right
it's only got one
alarm right and it rings the same for
all of these things and you said a
couple of things
most of the people i've sat with who are
considering
dying by suicide don't want to be dead
they want that pain to stop
yeah right
yeah and it's very quickly that you go
from i'm all by myself
to i'm being abandoned
to the danger zone which is other people
would be better if i just wasn't here
absolutely
listen it's not true
that's false
right
no you just said right passively so i'd
shut up i'm gonna say it again
it's not true
okay
so we know the end point
everybody's life will be worse with you
going
what we have to work on is the gap
okay
okay
the va is failing you
that's a them problem not a u problem
okay
yeah
they're the one with the malfunction not
my not my brother justin
okay
okay
i do think what you've told me right now
have you ever considered um
taking a break
doing inpatient for 30 days
no i haven't why not
um
financial
purposes yeah you know don't care about
that
okay
um no i just never have considered that
do you have a jeep that's all jacked up
no
you don't what do you have no that's a
an o4 tacoma dude look at me making a
bad judgment good for you josh
i've talked to some vets and they're
like i can't afford it man and then
they've got like an f
350 that's all jacked up and whatever so
no no no no good for you
do what paid in cash attaboy
so when you say the words it's not going
to change
what do you mean
um
well i i guess that the sisyphus analogy
right i mean i can i can make progress
and then i'm just i'm just going to
slide back
um
have you ever thought about stop pushing
i don't think i would know what that
looks like that's exactly right
would you be willing to look at this as
not a series of failures but as a
remember the first time they
they put that ar in front of you and
they told you how to take it apart and
put it back together it was just a
series of skills that you had to learn
if the idea of rest and the idea of
recalibration and the idea of re-um
learning some new tools to
differentiate the alarms and turn them
down for god's sake
if you could look at that as a series of
tools or in a series of skills
does that sit well with you
because that's a solvable problem
oh no absolutely absolutely it does i
think that's what i'm looking for okay
okay
i just don't know what that looks like
that's fair that's absolutely fair 100
percent fair
so
here's what i need from you
your wife said you started going to
counseling you found somebody else local
yes good how's that going yeah
awesome awesome okay yeah
will you make a blood oath to me
that you won't take your life until
that's over
yes
will you make a
in concrete oath to your wife that you
won't take your life
yes and we've we've done that we did the
uh the whole contract and and everything
okay here here's the gap though
it's good to make that contract
but you got to have a number to call
when it comes because it will
you can't will pay power that
right right do you have a number to call
i do you've made that promise
i have okay do you have a group of a
couple of local guys you can get
together with
i do
i will set up with you if you'll come
have coffee with me and hang out here
you're just down the street from me
we'll set that up if you're interested
yeah would you come hang out with me and
just have just honor me with hanging out
i'm not gonna fix you i'm not your
therapist but we can just have coffee
and hang out
that would be great i'll say i would buy
the coffee but they give it out free
here so that would just me be trying to
like self-ingrain dies
even better no that's great
you do that all right hang on the line
and jenna's gonna get your contact info
and then we'll loop up there i just
wanna hang out with you meet you you
live in my neighborhood okay sure is
that cool i'll buy lunch and we'll hang
out is that fun
right on yeah okay i'll also do
everything that i can and i can't
promise anything but when we meet in
person hopefully i'll have some stuff
for you and see if i can short circuit
some of the processes here in this local
community and get you some resources
okay
wow i don't know if that's possible but
i'll make the calls at least at least
make people uncomfortable how about that
how about that
cool okay thank you but yeah you are
promising me that you're going to be
here when i call
yes
awesome
hey i am
i'm proud of you
thank you
i am more proud of you for this
than for getting on an airplane earlier
that you had to do this is you're
deciding to do and i'm proud of you
thank you
okay
thank you
you're not broken
no one will be better off if you're not
here
and we're going to walk alongside you
the best we can
you just got to promise keep walking
we're in it
i'll keep walking hell yeah it's awesome
it's been one of my great honors to talk
to you today
okay thank you thank you josh and if you
see me in the neighborhood
say hi is that cool
i will we probably share a walmart or
something
probably there's only one right yeah
exactly
all right brother hey it's a blessing to
you i love you and thank you so so so
much for calling man
as we wrap up today's show let's see
here the band is need to breathe and the
song is called oh man look at that
brother goes like this
ramblers in the wilderness we can't find
what we need we get a little restless
from the searching get a little worn
down in between like a bull chasing the
matadors the man left to his own schemes
everybody needs somebody beside him
shining like a lighthouse from the sea
brother let me be your shelter never
leave you all alone i can be the one you
call when you're low brother let me be
your fortress when the night winds are
driving on be the one to light the way
bring you home
brother justin
you've done your fair share of being
other people's fortress now it's time to
let other people join you
and if you're listening to this show and
you've got people in your community that
are hurting
be the call
we'll see you later
coming up on the next episode my 21 year
old son about a month ago suffered a
mental breakdown i found out that this
mental health system is it's really it's
really
difficult to navigate um yes help my son
it's a mess if i if i break my ankle
doctor i go to the er and i get it fixed
i get a cast on if i break something in
my brain no one seems to know how to
how to help you or help my son your
son's not broken
he's not dysfunctional and he's not lost
when did the story that you didn't look
right to begin
like was your
family like always on a diet and always
talking about weight and stuff like that
and that is true for me but it wasn't
directed at me it was mostly like my dad
children absorb their environment
in a mainline fashion